a female poet and we do a woman should  receive an education but it should not  be the same as a man maybe they're  scared that if they teach us how the  world works we'll figure out how to take  over I don't know how the two of you fit  into such a tiny bed I don't  I have one purpose to become a great  writer  there's nothing you can do to stop me  hey she's so insane of course she's  insane she's Emily Dickinson you need to  cut out these sort of antics all you  have to do some things to desperate  times girl  don't look like you're dead while you're  still alive  if you want something to reach out  you'll be the only Dickerson they talked  about in 200 years I promise you that  that's a lovely funeral thank you thank  you might not be better  you  you